a good morning uh uh Kay just just to
declare an interest and to put my cards
in the table I benefited from free
school Mills as a child I know the
difference it made to my mom and dad
both of whom were working it was
literally a lifeline and gave them
breathing space financially to to be
able to know that my siblings and I
would have a you know nutritious hot
meal during the course of the day I
recognized that there are literally
millions of families in London who are
struggling with a rising cost of living
crisis unfortunately to be eligible for
free School meals your household income
has got to be less than seven thousand
four hundred pounds after paying taxes
irrespective of the number of children
you have so we're hearing stories about
parents skipping meals so their kids can
eat teachers bringing in food so their
students can eat and even heartbreaking
stories about children without pack lens
not on a free School Meal pretending to
eat around the lunch table at school to
avoid embarrassment so what I'm able to
do is announce 130 million pounds so
every child in a primary school in
London from the next school year for at
least a year will have a a free School
Meal a nutritious hot meal during the
course of the day but also the key thing
hey I remember is that feeling of Shame
and embarrassment because I had to get
my free School Meal voucher separate
from my friends see eat separately from
the majority of pupils because we've got
our voucher late and we're making it
Universal there will be no shame no
embarrassment no Stigma
what about Secondary School students
what I'm hoping the government does is
sees that if London can afford to do
this with the limited Pals resources we
have worlds are bringing it in in 2020
for the government wakes up to the
importance of all of our children having
at least one nutritious meal during the
course of the day you know PWC did some
research and they looked at the cost of
universal free school Mills in primary
school and secondary schools versus the
benefits a better educational attainment
better physical health better mental
health better productivity and there was
a net benefit of more than 2.46 billion
pounds so I'm hoping the government
particularly during a cost living crisis
partly reduce their policies recognizes
the importance of All Families
benefiting from a universal free School
meals
talking about
um
families benefiting I'm just reading as
I'm as you're chatting to me about unite
Union wanting you to hold the Euless
expansion scheme ultra low emission Zone
scheme they say it's anti-worker can't
afford it
can I just explain this particularly to
those watching this program because
there's lots of misinformation about our
policies to clean up the poisonous air
in London toxic air is a matter of life
and death every year in our city around
4 000 people 4 000 people lose their
lives directly linked to the poor
quality of children with stunted lungs
forever because of the poor quality
adults with a whole host of Health which
is from asthma to cancer dementia and
heart disease and it's the poorest
londoners at least likely to own a car
often members of trade unions who suffer
the worst consequences so what I've
announced is an extension of the policy
which also was opposed in 2017 the Euros
in central London in 2019 I announced
expansion to in London also opposed and
what Imperial College say is there is no
other policy in the world that's led to
the improvements in air quality that the
Euless has an almost 50 reduction in
toxic air so I've announced an expansion
to Outer London but also a package of
more than 171 million pounds for low
income families for those who are
disabled for sole Traders for small
businesses and for Charities to receive
support from two thousand pounds to nine
thousand five hundred pounds and I'd
encourage your viewers to go in the tfl
Checker transfer London Checker to see
whether your vehicle is eligible it more
than likely is a a compliant vehicle 84
Bitcoin 94 of vehicles in in London
already are compliant 85 of vehicles at
outside then already complying and 70 of
households low income households don't
even own a car
how would you have reacted I'm just
referring now to obviously where we are
in Lancashire you'll know very well the
story about uh Nicola bully how would
you have reacted of your Police Service
had released the information that
Lancashire police released about Nicola
bully
can I firstly say chaos I suspect
Nicholas family will be watching my
thoughts and prayers and other thoughts
and prayers are with them at this really
difficult uh time I'm unclear without
knowing the facts what the purpose was
for disclosing personal information
about nickel I don't understand what it
achieved
I can sort of understand why that sort
of information
may be of important to the public public
interest at the beginning of a missions
person's uh investigation I'm unclear at
the reasons why the police revealed that
information when they did I'm hoping I'm
praying that the family were aware that
police were going to do that because I
can imagine that adding that compounding
the feelings they've been going through
and now what's going to happen is a
proper look at what went on during the
investigation but at this stage the most
important thing is for that family to
receive the right support and comfort
they need
yeah and I thought just before I let you
go for the families this morning as they
wait to hear the news whether a body
that has been found in the river less
than a mile away from where Nicola bully
was last seen is that of their loved one
it is heartbreaking uh it's like I I
can't imagine anything as scary as a
loved one going uh Missing there's been
a lot of media attention on this case
rightly so
um but also I think many questions will
be asked about the police investigation
I know from speaking to other families
have gone through something similar you
sort of hope and pray and it sounds
perverse to say this that the person
that's been found isn't your your loved
one and there's an explanation for what
your loved one is let's wait and see how
what happens with the identity but
whatever happens uh Nicholas family will
need support but also we should respect
I suspect their wish for privacy during
this difficult time
okay um it's always good to talk to Mr
thanks for joining us this morning